i stand squarely behind my decision
after 20 years
i've learned the hard way
that there was never a good time to
withdraw
u.s forces
that's why we're still there
we were clear-eyed about the risk
we plan for every contingency but
i always promise the american people
that i will be straight with you
the truth is
this did unfold more quickly
than we had anticipated
so what's happened
afghanistan political leaders gave up
and fled the country
the afghan military
collapsed sometime without
trying to fight
if anything
the developments of the past week
reinforced that ending u.s military
involvement afghanistan now
was the right decision
american troops cannot
and should not
be fighting in a war and dying in a war
that afghan forces are not willing to
fight for themselves
let me lay out the current mission in
afghanistan
i was asked to authorize when i did 6
000 u.s troops to deploy to afghanistan
for the purpose of assisting the
departure of u.s and allied civilian
personnel from afghanistan
and to evacuate our afghan allies and
vulnerable afghans to safety outside of
afghanistan
our troops are working to secure the
airfield
and ensure continued operation
of both the civilian and military
flights
operation allies refugee
which i announced back in july
has already moved 2 000 afghans who are
eligible for special immigration visas
and their families to the united states
in the coming days
the us military will provide assistance
to move to move more siv eligible
afghans and their families out of
afghanistan